inside Bridget and Shonda Rhimes okay
behind the hit series you know that's
good it is published by an imprint of
Simon and Schuster which like CBS is
part of Paramount Global so Nate and I
talked to them earlier this week Tony
was on assignment but Nate and I were
still here so they we talked to them
about creating the phenomenon and how it
started with Julia Quinn's Bridgeton
novels
let's just go briefly back to the
beginning Shonda because this series
came you're sick you're in a hotel room
2017 you pick up this book and you think
what I pick up this book it's a romance
novel I just needed something to read
because I wasn't feeling well and I
couldn't put it down and I was sick I
mean it was good enough that I got up
out of my sick bed in the hotel room and
went to buy the second book I mean and
then she reaches out to you Betsy and
you said romance novel that's exactly
you hadn't read a romance novel since
you were what uh probably my teens a
teenager 18's and I said are you sure
you're feeling okay yes and I kept
saying just read it just read it and
then everybody would read it and they
got what I got which was exciting and
what did you get you know what was
interesting it didn't it felt like it
was about me or about any woman like I
could see myself in the characters even
though we're talking about Regency
England even though originally all the
characters were white it was a world
that I wanted to inhabit this amazing
world of the ton and the marriage Mart
and all these gowns and just the romance
of it all felt strong you know what I
like I like how you all handle sex
because during that time period number
one it seems like sex would be a lot of
work just going through all those
costumes
take this down it just seems like let's
see an hour once you get undressed
you'll see you in an hour but you you've
locked onto something called the
feminine gaze Betsy that I really like
because it's sexual and steamy with and
and from a woman's perspective woman's
point of view yeah listen they had one
scene with the spoon with regular I
thought God I wish I could be a spoon oh
my God and it's just him just licking on
a spoon when I think we actually that's
one of the great things we cover in the
book yeah exactly that is I was not
alone you were thinking you were
absolutely not alone in that thinking
absolutely and it does feel like women
have the right to have that gaze and
have that gay scene what is the feminine
gaze though it's really sort of looking
at all of these sexual scenes from the
point of view of a woman yeah usually
you see scenes from the point of evil
man of course you know their clothes
women's clothes are off there's a
million shots of their bodies it's not
about what the woman's experience there
with the woman's saying it's about some
male fantasy we want it to go the other
way yeah and you mentioned earlier about
the original characters being white and
it's rare to see people of color why was
that important to make sure that that
was put in Bridgeton well I mean I'm not
going to make a show that doesn't
somehow number one but
to ratio we talked we talked about this
of people of color in that time period
there were black composers there were
black artists there were all these
people and we wanted to have a chance to
tell that story so we went from the idea
what if Queen Charlotte as has been said
in history it really is biracial and
told the story from there you said you
became obsessed with Queen Charlotte I'm
obsessed because it just made a show
about her yes she's glamorous and
glorious but also you know as played by
Golda is probably I mean I was calling
like the Beyonce of the show there's
nobody like her nothing bad about
Beyonce nothing bad about it he also has
the best wigs exactly I think in the
history of wigdom and that's what you
all write about the thing that I also
like about this book May I mention it
again yeah inside Bridgerton you all
it's like you took every component of
the show the costumes the food The
Styling the writers the writers the
dancing you wanted to do a love letter
to the crew yeah and I think so many
people don't really understand what it
takes to make a show this big and
hopefully people people will you know
read this book and read the behind the
scenes and see these photos and go back
to the show and watch it again and see
it an entirely different light it's
about the Bridget and siblings this is
what I learned in the book that they're
all in alphabetical order yes can you do
as a quick tick tock I never realized
that Anthony Benedict Colin Daphne
Eloise Francesca Gregory Hyacinth now
we'll talk about the beginning of
something the beginning of your
relationship yeah I've known each other
20 years about that yeah in the first
project you guys worked on together it
didn't take off we wrote a pilot about
war correspondence that was the first
thing and and neither one of us had
worked in television before I was
obsessed with journalists and we wrote
this pilot about war correspondence and
it didn't get made so then the next time
around the next season we thought well
what should we make and we both were
obsessed with surgeries and medical
stuff and we knew that they were looking
for a medical show but we also like this
idea of these incredibly competitive
women like in their workplace I never
really understood medical shows yeah so
when we were excited about the idea I
said I love medical shows but I never
understand what's going on they get
digestible there are these people called
interns and they don't know what they're
doing either yeah so it was the most
amazingly wonderful way in for a medical
show in so Shonda wrote this incredible
pilot and we made it we're talking
Gray's Anatomy in 2005. yeah which is
now the longest running Prime Time
medical drama in TV and TV history how
about that there she goes showing off
again Nate of all your hits in
Chandelier I know it would be like
picking your favorite child you've got
three gorgeous daughters yeah it's
always hard to pick a favorite but is
there one that that holds a special
place because I look at graze and I look
at Scandal I mean I think of them all
my scandal
such a place in my heart yes I learned
that I could actually enjoy the process
as opposed to just having my head down
and working so I got to have a lot of
fun on skin yeah and I really enjoyed
that
and guess what Shonda Rhimes and her
partner they are still having fun inside
Bridgerton is on sale now and she says
in chandeland you don't always have
Happy Endings but in Bridgerton with the
eight siblings they take each each
sibling tell their story and they she
wants them all to have a happy ending
she can reel off the names like they
were her own family like they were real
people that's amazing Dale so your
favorite scene is the spoon scene you
know I like that spoon hide the spoons
not the only one yeah